herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
hallo keiner vorbei heute spielen wir
eine neue zuschauer challenge in jump
natürlich und wir haben gleich zwei
anwendung einmal von the hunter die
piraten change du musst die runde mit
nur einem auge gewinnen augenklappe und
also und so neo der lustigerweise auch
aus piraten macht des weges
zusammengefasst so nie gesagt du musst
sie mal kommt in game sprache auf pirat
ich ändern und das texture pack spec
reintun das heißt leute heute wird
einfach der totale abfahrt ganz ehrlich
es wird einfach ein abfall okay aber es
wird sicher unterhaltsam
ich habe hier noch diesen sturm waffe
bad daran erinnern sich vielleicht auch
noch ein paar genießt einfach mit mir
wie ich heute heute einfach den
stürmischen skill auspacke hier und ich
habe mit ihnen stimme bat jetzt hier so
als augenklappe als 15 einer augenklappe
über das gesicht geben aber hier seht
ihr dass eine öffnung drin die müssen
erst mal zusammentreten
so zu dem zweck habe ich jetzt hier so
komisches verbands klebeband weil ich
keine markante safin leisten kann
herr stephan i das überkleben
ja das sieht das auch aktion gestartet
oh okay alles klar das ist überklebt gut
jetzt noch zwei dinge minecraft sprach
auch pirat ich ändern wobei ich nehme
wissen was wir machen wir machen es
fanny wir stellen erst piraten und
packen dann das texture pack raus
wahrscheinlich schaffen es einfach nicht
aber hey piratebay org in nikes carril
endlagers landet waterpark alles klar
med menden chip changes praktikers
texture pack hallo tipp fließtext gebäck
irgendwie irgendwo
kurz noch mal zurück zu deutsch ich
finde es gerade nicht um mit paris
möglich klar ich kann nicht auswendig ok
schnell zurück deutsch deutsch motto
läuft ok bitte nicht quatschen kitas der
option auch ressourcen paketes da unten
also ok kraus und kubick kraft heißt das
not expect links und jetzt leute die
anderen sicher bei 30 prozent
alles kein problem denn ich bin hawking
pirat ich hoffe niemand der mich kennen
sie das
dennoch sprach er wieder auf pirat files
pik und da syrien werde die anderen 285
scheiß junge max junge einfach nur was
ohne witz einfach nur ein fettes fettes
what the [ __ ] an mich selbst dafür dass
ich das hier gerade mache die wahlsieger
sind sagen sollte es ist einfach dumm
war zwölfter der unten solltest sein
okay ich kenne dieses modul nicht
erkennt wir aber ich glaube einfach mal
okay dass man leider alles klar
die ist leider alles klar jetzt auch die
wahl und blogs gold digger zwei modulen
deckt of poker und wir sind schon nicht
mehr letzter auch bauer aber schnell
zurück
okay in einem auge zu spielen bisschen
komisch junge ich schwöre ich bin der
brocks pirat aller zeiten goethes bitte
damit wir das bitte bestätigen könnte es
bestätigen die kommentar hat sich der
pirat aller zeiten bin aber auch mit
einem auge minecraft zu spielen ist
komisch denn der mensch normalerweise
beide augen um distanzen richtig
einschätzen können
okay dass man die kenne ich aber das
erkenne ich direkt wieder komischerweise
ist glas doch irgendwie drin
keine ahnung warum aber ist die nächste
kiste und wir haben uns gut geschlagen
es gut die leute sie verlassen schon die
runde seht ihr das ich weiß gar nicht ob
wirklich jemand die runde verlassen hat
vielleicht sollte ich einfach weiter
fucking random sieht das ja das ist auf
jeden fall heute die verwirrte runde
jumpy die jemals gesehen habt wenn ihr
irgendwo leute wenn ihr irgendeine ohne
job die gesehen habt ihr mehr verwirrend
ist bitte verlinken wir das video ich
glaube es nicht
ich glaube es ehrlich gesagt nicht dass
ihr irgendwas gesehen habt im leben was
ich mehr versteht als das hier ja wie
hier
daraus schließe ich erst mal das hier
glas ist ja oft ach nein das war zu weit
ich weiß jetzt schon ich werde mache
welches video geschnitten hat aber so
dasitzen mich so fragen okay gut du hast
jetzt aufgenommen aber wie zur hölle
nennen wir den scheiß weil keine ahnung
dass einzig passende wirkliches einzig
passende hier ist einfach nur die world
of xchange oder einfach nur ganz kurz
what the [ __ ] uns einfach keine ahnung
ich ist es nicht mal eine challenge es
ist einfach es ist einfach irre
ok jetzt okay aber das diesen drei
blocks und von hier kommen darunter ja
wohl derer die die ich laufe erst mal
rückwärts runter
ok ich erkenne wieder überhaupt nicht
was wenn du das hier ist ja okay hier
ist
aha okay ich glaube ich hab ne entfernt
idee ok hatchet und hatchet aus paris
pik und der katalyse goldmaske das
musketier natürlich kann ich bitte meine
zweites auge zurück arbeiter mit dem
zweiten sieht man einfach fucking besser
dankeschön zdf für eine million euro
kann ich kann ich spürte wie dein leben
zurückhaben
ich sitze hier gerade nehme nachts um
halb eins ich fürchte es ist nachts um
halb eins bei mir
minecraft auf minecraft rampling ich
bringe mein ganz videos immer nur ein
prima mai kräftig habe irgendein
komische blende im gesicht mein leben
ist außer kontrolle geraten ich habe
kein texture pack ich liebe paris blieb
mein leben ist außer kontrolle geraten
leute können helfen
ich schwöre ich liebe das man sowas sein
schön einfach einfach gestört dass diese
art von minecraft oder diese generell
diese art von youtube video das powder
keck assistent hier wahrscheinlich okay
dass diese art von video bei der ihr
wenn ihr solche anschaut und eure eltern
in den raum einkommen lieber pornos an
macht und seine eltern nicht erklären zu
müssen was hier einfach vor sich geht
aber ich muss sagen die sonne scheint
der himmel blau
mein leben liegt vor mir mehr oder
weniger und ok alles da das es sonst
cent und es heißt es es sind also die
items sind nicht gespritzt worden was
sinn macht weil die ein team namens ihr
aus dem texture pack stammen
eine augenklappe verrutscht meine sturm
auflaufen ja so viel besser so das ist
mein nun freigelegt wurde
so kann ich tatsächlich reden wird falls
irgendwann dieses video seht ihr mich
aus dem echten leben kennt und warum
junge ich wollte auch die kisten herr
ich dachte werden zeit fucking shit aber
okay wir sind full metal links komplett
haben unsere hatcher stil lemm polak der
abteilung bogen jetzt geht's ab bauer
da hat mich einer von hinten aber junge
hexe mit wem liegst du dich eigentlich
an die landräte denkst ich bin normaler
frei worte ich bin nett alter schwede
ich brauche keine pause gibt's einfach
zickzackkurs junge paar
es war wirklich okay
compass weiß kommt aus player trecker
ganz ehrlich kommt sowas kommt in der
seefahrt ein wirklich tagtäglich vor
da hätte man sich das besser ausdenken
können ich bin ich bin enttäuscht ich
kündige ich kündige mein
arbeitsverhältnis als minecraft spielen
der pirat und er wird auch junge ist so
easy einfach nur ja gut wir sind gerade
in stage mit drei mann reingegangen aber
haye hat keiner bemerkt und die
universums von vector fakten landrat
guck dir das an detailfragen ich sterbe
keine fragen der leute
solltet ihr auch also wenn dieses video
bisher hingeschaut hat stellt einfach
keine fragen
es ist einfach ein mensch wie er
durchdreht und einfach alles tennhardt
in jump liegt aber jetzt hab ich mein
herz okay ich kann nicht ich kann so
nicht kämpfen
ich habe nun herzen ich kann so nicht
kämpfe ich keinen gegner aus noten haben
soll
es geht einfach nicht okay hier wieder
zu herzen alles der wickerer kämpfen
ok ich hab' wieder neue herzen okay aber
auf dem spiekerplatz richtig dollar lag
auch er war im korb natürlich hoffe ich
dass kopf nicht gesehen im text effekt
alten omas jetzt komm du bist
vorleistung aber aber wenns geholt und
wir haben einen cleanen 15 0
deathmatch league gewonnen fast alle
kids und das match gemacht
reporter schien als wäre diese aufgabe
noch nicht gestört genug schreibt auch
noch eine report for joy sk ich
verabschiede mich ich glaub ich geh
jetzt in professionell beratungen las
mit tipps geben was ihr in meinem leben
sinnvolles anstellen könnte ansonsten ja
das war zu weit von mir wie immer
fleißig changes in die kommentare
schreiben
und hoch und runter bewerten wenn sie
euch gefallen oder nicht wir sehen uns
nächste video wieder schlecht vielleicht
dieser geistig gesund bis dahin
er weist bis dahin haut rein macht gut
und